يفتقدون الامانه في المخيمات هو حال تلك
الفئه من اللاجئين السوريين القلقين من
احتمال ترحيلهم
اكثرهم يخشى الحديث للاعلام درعا للمخاطر
اما من يجرؤ على الكلام فيؤكد على حقه
بالعوده الامنه لا بالترحيل القصري
هذه قيمه
نحن لا تحصلون على السكن بهذه الخيمه نحن
لو في هلا الارضيه الخاصه نقدر نامن على
حالنا وعلى اولادنا نحن ما بنبقى ولا سنه
اجراءات السلطات اللبنانيه استهدفت ايضا
الجمعيات التي تؤمن لهم المساعدات فهذا
المركز الطبي الذي يوفر خدمات للاجئين
والمواطنين في بلده عرسال مهدد بالاغلاق
نتيجه قرار تنظيمي من السلطات
مرحله استثنائيه عندما يتنافى الوجود
السوري في لبنان طبعا هذه المراكز كلها
موجوده فنتمنى نتمنى من المسؤولين ان جانب
هذا المواطن الى جانب هذه البلده الى جانب
لبنان وبينما تطالب الامم المتحده بان
تكون عوده اللاجئين طوعيه لا قصريه ترى
السلطات اللبنانيه انه يجب ترحيل من لا
يلتزم بالقوانين وتطالب الامم المتحده بان
تشطب من لوائحها اللاجئ الذي يزور بلاده
دوريا يشعر اللاجئون السوريون بالقلق من
ترحيل من لا يملكون اوراق النظاميه منهم
وذلك بعد تاكيد السلطات عزمها اعاده من
دخل منهم الى لبنان خلصتا ويتزامن ذلك مع
ما يوصف بخطاب التحريض ضد اللاجئين
السوريين وتاتي هذه الاجراءات مع تصاعد ما
يوصف بخطاب التحريض ضد اللاجئين في ظل
تفاقم الاوضاع الاقتصاديه في لبنان اذ ترى
السلطات ان وجود
الحق خسائر بالاقتصاد واثر على المجتمعات
المضيفه وهو ما تشكك به منظمات امميه صار
في موسميا كل سنه سنتين حاله تاجيج ضد
اللاجئين بالخطاب الرسمي تليها حملات يا
اما ترحيل يا اما تنظيم عوده طوعيه
الحكومه اللبنانيه جددت دعوتها المجتمع
الدولي الى تحمل مسؤولياته تجاه اللاجئين
وايجاد حل لازمتهم في ظل انفتاح العربي
على دمشق النزوح السوري صقله كبير على
لبنان
ونستطيع ان نقول تعبنا
قلنا انت لما بتحمل لك حق تعبنا ولكن لسنا
عنصريين وبدات السلطات اللبنانيه التحضير
لحمله جديده لما تصفها بالعوده الطوعيه
للاجئين السوريين وهو ما تحذر من مخاطره
جمعيات حقوقيه ترى ان شرط العوده الامنه
الى سوريا غير متوفر وان حياه العائدين قد
تكون مهدده ايهاب العقد الجزيره عرسال شرق
لبنان